[Music]
let's turn out of the u.s election
and the fallout from it joe biden was
declared the winner on saturday by the
us networks but donald trump is still
refusing to concede he's mounting a
number of legal challenges there will
probably be
some recounts where the result is
particularly
close though normally these recounts
for example georgia or arizona mr
biden's about 12
000 ahead no previous american recount
has ever moved the dial by anything
like that amount and actually even if mr
biden
was to lose arizona and georgia he would
still be
president the one that mr trump
really has to take back is pennsylvania
where mr biden's 50 000
ahead many republicans although they're
not saying publicly are now
saying privately look donald trump has
lost
joe biden will be the 46th president of
the united states
we just need mr trump to realize that
and move on
so what's going to happen to discuss the
fallout i'm joined by piers morgan
broadcaster author of wake up his book
on
walk britain and the warp world uh which
will be getting great reviews and is
selling all over the place
and i'm delighted he joins us now pierce
i know it's hard to tell
but what do you think
the president's game plan is
uh i think he's trying to find one i
think he knows that he's lost
and he hates losing we know this he is
pathologically
unaligned to the concept of losing
but he's lost so what does a guy like
that do
at the moment i think he's thrashing
around in the net
trying to get out and there's actually
no escape route i mean you've just
articulated
the reality of what is going on here
there are six
states that he's contesting i think
there's only one state at the moment
where technically he's even able to have
a recap because it has to be a certain
percentage that it has to fall below
so in the other five as i understand it
right now
it hasn't reached that threshold so he's
not even entitled to a recount but
even if he has the recounts he's likely
to lose most of them and he certainly
isn't going to win pennsylvania
so he's not going to be president i
think there's probably something else
going on here
i think it's two-fold i think trump
wants to rally the base
because of this extraordinary situation
in georgia where you have the two senate
uh
seats in georgia both up for grabs in a
rerun
because neither the candidates got more
than 50 percent of the vote
and the significance of that is it will
determine who has control
of the senate and that's a hugely
important thing in fact you could argue
more important
than who's sleeping at the white house
um you know bear in mind
the wider context here the republicans
had a pretty damn good election
you know trump himself got seven million
more votes
than he got in 2016. he got four to five
million more
than hillary got when she won this
massive popular vote
yes he came below biden by about five
million and biden got the most ever
but trump is the second highest vote
count in the history
of presidential elections plus they will
probably keep the senate i think is
the way things look they gained seats in
the house
when many predicted them to lose a
handful of seats
so on almost every box that you want to
take you would say
the republicans had a good election um
trump i think is
marshalling the base to make sure they
win
in georgia i think he's also marshalling
his exit
to make it less like a loss and more
like a fix by the establishment
the swamp came along to try and prevent
him getting re-elected
and the reason for that may be that he
wants to run again
in 2024 or at the very least he wants a
trump on the ticket
be it ivanka or donald jr and people who
think that's unlikely
need to understand just how big trump
is in america between the flyover states
and just how big his popularity is seven
million more people
voted for trump after seeing him as
president for four years
and that included more muslims he got 35
percent
of the entire muslim vote in america
more lgbtq
voters voted for trump this time than
last time more black voters
voted for trump than last time and more
latino and hispanic voters voted for
trump
these are extraordinary statistics and
ones that if you're the republican party
you're thinking
biden's getting a bit of a hospital pass
here coronavirus
is completely out of control uh he may
not have control of the senate so his
ability
to do very much in that first term is
severely limited and you could see a
situation in three
years time where up pops big bad donald
or one of his family would donald
support to say
i told you i warned you the economy
might be flatlining
coronavirus might be still causing
problems i'm here to save you all
right well hold that thought and let me
of 2024
i'll come back to that and let me come
back to 2020 in early 2021.
you see if i was a gop strategist a
republican strategist
listening to everything you said i would
say you're absolutely right
2020 was not a disaster for us despite
the pandemic
despite the fact that the economy tanked
because of the pandemic and
and this thing that we hope would win as
the election the the economy was not in
the shape
it should have been despite all that mr
biden was almost dragged across the
winning
winning line we even won seats in the
house nobody saw that coming
uh looks like we got on to the senate we
also have got a conservative majority in
the supreme court
so i get all that but what i'd be
worried about is that this
donald trump clinging on to the white
house but everybody knows he's lost
uh it's unseemly it's ungracious it's
not american
it's not america and that is undermining
the fact that the gop
did pretty it lost the white house but
it did pretty well
that would be my concern yeah i
completely agree i wrote an open letter
to him
uh for the daily mail website saying
come on donald you've lost it's over
kaput you're done
um you know go gracefully because
actually that will play well
with a lot of people in america if trump
was to suddenly do an about face
and say okay all right i've exhausted my
legal remedy and i think he wants to get
to that stage before he does this
i've exhausted my legal remedy i accept
i've lost
i don't agree but i accept i've lost uh
if he does that that would actually go a
long way i think to
especially with independence thinking
yeah okay he's maybe not such a bad
beast after all
um it's whether trump has that in him i
and i don't you know i know him very
well i spoke to him a couple of weeks
ago for half an hour he
rang me out of the blue had a long
conversation um i just don't know if he
has it in him
to admit that he's lost and if he
doesn't do that and say for argument's
sake he snubs the inauguration
and doesn't turn up and goes out as the
biggest loser and a really sore bad
loser
you know i think ultimately the damage
is to him
it won't be to the democratic process
because the democratic process
will go past trump in a past when the
electoral college
finally to zach together in the second
week of december that's it
there's nothing more trump can do and if
he has to be removed forcefully by
secret service from the white house
that is what will happen so he can huff
and puff and try
and blow the house down but the house is
not going to get blown down
joe biden come january 21st will be
president
and i want to ask you about what you
make of mr biden so far but before
i do let's just finish off on the trump
side of things and looking
forward i mean i don't know if mr trump
thinks he can run again
i think that will partly be determined
by the manner of his departure
or whether some of the family is i mean
donald jr seems to be
almost as big a fantasist as his father
when it comes to i mean i was looking at
the downright lies he told about uh turn
out in wisconsin
saying it was up to 85 percent that was
just a lie
but what he had done was take up the
turnout as a percentage of registered
voters
not as what had been done in his 2016
figures as a percentage
of eligible voters you do that and turn
up in wisconsin's up about five points
which is par for the course in an
election we saw
a good turnout but it does seem to me if
you were looking at the future of the
republican party
that even if mr trump has gone even if
he
he's not a player for the next election
there is a trumpian element that remains
to the republican party
that they really need they they are now
more the party of blue collar workers
than country club republicans they are
in some ways
more a party of big government than the
reagan limited government
conservatism of the west coast
what he's done will continue to be a
major element
in the republican party whoever the
candidate is in 2024
and also of course who is the biggest
driver
of tv ratings and newspaper circulations
in america right now it's donald j trump
the media
needs trump even as they tell us how
much they hate trump
they've conspired against him with the
exception of fox news for four years
and he's still got seven million more
voters trump bashing has been very
lucrative for the media in america
and it's been very helpful to trump in
rallying his base and getting people
to position him as a kind of robin hood
figure standing up against the
establishment so
it's very hard to see if you're the
republican party you're thinking
okay we can steer well away from this we
can ignore trump we can
park him into a corner where he shouts
some rats on tv
all day but actually he's got huge
popularity
he's just had the second biggest vote in
american presidential history
and he's got this whole built-in first
family all of whom will be gagging to be
president if he doesn't want to be i
genuinely think trump is going to
say when he finally concedes if he
concedes but when he has to leave the
white house
that he's going to run in 2024 and he'll
basically spend the next four years
being donald trump and the media will
have to ask themselves a difficult
question
are we going to go on the trump train
like we've done for the last four years
because we know it boosts our ratings
and circulation
or are we going to go for a more boring
republican
alternative and i think it's going to be
very interesting test
for the media because in a way they've
all been in this abusive marriage
and they all need each other you
mentioned the media
which i'm going to i want to ask you
about that before i will with a final
question come
to joe biden uh if it wasn't for fox and
we all know the weaknesses and the
the problems and sometimes outrageous
behavior of thoughts
if it wasn't for folks america would
essentially be a one-party state when it
comes to media
no it would be a left-wing one-party
state all the other
networks all the major newspapers with
the exception of the wall street journal
which is the same ownership
as fox are pretty much democrat and on
the left of the democrat party
don't you get a feeling it's not kind of
off the reservation the way it's
behaving
some of the things that anchor men and
women are saying
are just impartiality has just entirely
gone out the window
uh this cnn anchor describing mr trump
there's a sort of an obese turtle on his
back
playing around somebody else crying
because joe biden has won crying
with joy that he is one pulling away
from things now because they don't like
what's being said
i mean i i mean for someone who was
brought up in america
on the cbs of walter cronkite and the
nbc
of john chancellor and uh and so on and
all
it just seems incredible to me pierce
well
as somebody who worked at cnn for four
years it seems pretty incredible to me
when i watched cnn and funnily enough
you know where was the real authority
and power and cnn's coverage
in that final election week it came from
the completely impartial
anchors like wolf blitzer john king the
people who do not
actually fall into that trap of
revealing their personal opinions
we actually turn to them for what we
deem to be genuinely impartial accurate
up-to-date information not the partisan
ones like anderson cooper
who by calling trump this you know
bloated orange turtle whatever
made it crystal clear as he has done for
four years that he hates trump
and wants him out of office but once an
anchor does that then cnn
can no longer profess to be an impartial
network it's a network that has a lot of
very partisan
anchors now and that's a commercial
decision that's made them tons of money
but it's not the cnn that i worked at
and i think the big question
going forward is where do americans go
for genuinely
impartial news coverage and the answer
is there's nowhere
there's no newspaper which is impartial
particularly there's no
tv network which i think you could
categorize now as being completely
impartial
it's almost completely liberal skewed in
a way i'm pleased there is fox news
at least it gives some counter balance
to the 90 percent liberal skewed media
so it's a problem for american it's a
problem for their democratic system the
american people
have nowhere to go now where they can
genuinely believe they're getting
completely impartial news as it happens
piers final question joe biden uh
so far so good i would suggest he's
handled
he's in a difficult situation as the
incoming president given
uh mr trump's behavior uh but he's just
getting on with the job he's just doing
what you do
in this interregnum of 11 weeks between
election day and the inauguration
and the people that seem to be around
him seem to be very
sensible it's kind of an obama redux
team
and he as i say so far he seems to me
anyway
to be doing pretty well well he's of
course incredibly experienced 50 years
in washington
um but also he he crucially has the one
thing trump definitely doesn't have
he has empathy in spades and he has an
ability to show empathy to the american
people he's recognized how fractured
america is
probably as fractured as he's ever seen
in his political career
and bear in mind he goes back to the
late 60s early 70s that's quite a
statement
you know i've only had one dealing with
joe biden but it showed me the kind of
man he is he was
i wrote a column about his son beau when
he died of brain cancer in his mid-40s
about
uh six years ago and he was then vice
president joe biden he rang me out of
the blue to thank me for the column
and i knew beau quite well i met his i
met jill biden joe's wife and we had a
chat about that but then
i asked him as a father of four i said
you've now had to bury
your first wife and your baby daughter
who were killed in a car crash when you
were
just turning senator age 30. your two
boys survived and one of those boys has
now died too
i can't imagine losing a child how have
you dealt with this and he just told me
a little story that's an awful lot about
joe biden he's you know his father
after his wife and baby girl died sent
him a framed cartoon
of hagar the horrible and it was in two
parts and in the first part
hagar was in a stormy ocean trapped on a
rock
his ship floundering with thunder and
lightning and he raised his trident to
the skies and said to the gods and said
why me
and the second half had the gods
shouting back or god
as joe put it shouting back well why not
why not you and it was his father's way
of telling him you can't rationalize
tragedy and you can't let it crush you
by trying to rationalize it
you just have to accept bad stuff's
going to happen and i think the terrible
double tragedy he's endured in his life
has given joe biden a genuine
deep-rooted
empathy and right now america is reeling
from the worst coronavirus death toll in
the world rocketing case numbers now in
almost every state is reeling from the
fallout of the appalling
killing of george floyd and the protests
in which trump singularly failed to calm
things he just pulled fuel on the fire
and i think biden is very cleverly
positioning himself
as the nation's healer it's easier said
than done
but it's good to see somebody saying it
from the presidential pulpit
good story to go out home pierce pierce
morgan a joy to have you on spectator tv
thank you for your time we'll let you go
now we know just how busy you are
here's morgan there get his book wake up
uh or it's a great insight into all
things walk
uh and uh it's a perfect uh stocking
filler for christmas
thanks sandra all the best
[Music]
you